ce jeune il est intéressant il a une
maladresse quelque chose de pur
s'assimile pas ils s'appellent james
dean je veux faire un sujet sur l'ut sur
un acteur inconnu l'appelle jean denys 1
alors on les fait ces photos qui va me
rendre célèbre je te garantis
ça vous dirait d'aller prendre un verre
il ya quelque chose dans l'air
change la musique là à la photo jimmy en
fait partie je peux pas envoyer sa lane
un type à l'air chaud c'est ça ton
nouveau leader je suis warner est
vraiment derrière votino john barrymore
douglas fairbanks cac n'est il suivait
certaines règles quand tu seras un très
beau gars tu pourras trouver tes amis
faut que tu joues le jeu encore quelques
semaines les spires history quoi qu'il
t'arrive ça n'est pas par hasard
je veux me perdre dans mes rôles il est
hors de question que je me terme dans
tout le reste il est pas fiable toujours
changeants c'est un artiste et moi aussi
j'en suis qu'est ce que tu fabriques à
les envoyer tous balader en skate dc
non sans rire tu as grandi ici
on est tous très heureux que tu sois là
avec nos nous sommes très fiers de toi
tu peux pas rentrer sans rien
afellay forêt changer d'avis j'suis
flutie persuadé qu'il trouverait quelque
chose de magnifique et que je saurais
pas faire et que life aimerait le
problème c'est que tu es venu ici en
pensant que j'étais le sujet de cette
petite virée
tout change si vite une photo c'est un
moyen de dire j'étais là et étaient là
l'espoir fait vivre